Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, we're going to continue
talking about tissue engineering
today.
I introduced the subject on
Tuesday and I'm going to talk
about some more examples that
sort of illustrate this new
approach to creating medical
therapies.
I just wanted to remind you
before about the two readings
that are already posted on the
website and to encourage you to
look at those to get a sense for
how the field has developed over
the last 20 years or so.
Last time I used this sort
of outline as a guide of,
at least, my view of the
characteristics of tissue
engineering.
We talked about it at the
beginning of class last time,
there's a logical extension of
conventional medical and
surgical practices.
In that sense a solution,
potentially a solution to the
limited number of donor organs
that are available to treat
diseases where transplantation
of tissue is the only option.
Many approaches to tissue
engineering involve regulating
your body's natural response.
We can heal,
in many cases,
and regenerate.
The liver is a--for example
is a fabulously regenerative
organ.
If you go into a laboratory
animal, like a rat,
if you remove two-thirds of
their liver,
their liver will re-grow within
a period of a couple of weeks.
The liver has an amazing
regenerative capacity.
There are human diseases where
that regenerative capacity is
overwhelmed.
Infection can be that kind of a
disease, hepatitis infection,
for example;
cirrhosis is that kind of
infection.
When you get past the body's
natural ability to heal itself,
then transplantation is the
only option.
In tissue engineering,
we might be thinking about a
different strategy,
could we provide some support
for the body's own ability to
heal?
Could you provide a little bit
of extra liver tissue that would
allow the body an opportunity to
compensate for its loss?
Tissue engineering involves
control or regulation of the
normal healing process.
Today I'm going to start by
talking about how it attempts to
replace or supplement the
cellular component of diseased
tissues.
When a tissue is diseased,
for example,
when we talked about the
coronary arteries and needing a
bypass,
you're adding extra cells or
extra tissue there because
medical therapies,
at least the ones we have now,
are not effective at
re-establishing the blood flow
pathway.
You're adding new cells and
they have to be cells that are
in the correct configuration.
They have to be cells like a
vessel, and they have to be
performing the functions that
cells ordinarily provide.
I talked about how we couldn't
use completely synthetic
materials to replace that blood
vessel,
even though a synthetic
material would provide a conduit
for blood.
Because the material properties
aren't right,
it isn't the same as the
natural cellular layer,
then blood coagulates on the
surface.
It doesn't provide that normal
function that cells provide.
We want to think about ways to
replace or supplement that
cellular component.
Let me talk about one
example.
This is an example that I've
been working on in my own lab,
together with two different
laboratories at the medical
school,
Jordan Pober in Immunology and
Al Bothwell in Immunology.
It really uses a strategy
that's been used in laboratories
around the world to try to
re-establish tissues in animals.
The technique is fairly
straightforward and shown in
this cartoon,
that cells are cultured.
These are special cells in a
couple of different ways.
One is they are human cells,
and they are harvested from
human umbilical veins.
The umbilical vein,
which is normally discarded
after delivery,
the baby is born,
the umbilical cord and the
placenta are ordinarily
discarded.
If you keep that tissue,
you can isolate the cells that
form the lining of that tissue.
It's a vein and what you get
from this isolation are
endothelial cells.
It's abbreviated here HUVEC,
that stands for 'human
umbilical vein endothelial
cells.'People have learned
over the past few decades how to
maintain these cells in culture,
how to propagate them,
how to increase them in number
using the same techniques we
talked about very near the
beginning of the course.
They've also discovered how to
genetically modify these cells
so that they perform better in
culture.
One of these modifications is
to add a gene called
Bcl-2.
Bcl-2 is a survival gene
that allows these cells to live
beyond when you would expect
them to live.
If you just take human
umbilical vein,
endothelial cells,
and you propagate them and
culture you can passage them.
Remember the process of
passaging from one tissue
culture to another,
always getting more and more
cells.
You can do that for some
limited period of time,
but if you give them this
survival gene,
Bcl-2, you can do that for a
much longer period of time,
you can get more cells.
Cells are grown from human
tissues.
The idea is to somehow get
these cells into an animal,
or into a patient,
and get them to reform blood
vessels inside the patient.
The way that this is done is
that these cells are suspended
in a three-dimensional gel.
This is a gel of collagen and
it looks just like this scanning
electron micrograph.
On the side,
if you looked at very high
magnification,
it's just a web or a network of
protein fibers formed from the
natural protein collagen.
We talked about collagen's role
in the extracellular matrix
earlier.
Here, this is isolated
collagen, purified,
and then formed into a gel,
and cells are suspended within
it.
That's what this picture down
here is to show you.
This is a high magnification;
a cell in here would be almost
the same size as this full
picture would be a cell,
and so you can imagine each
cell that's suspended in this
three-dimensional material is
surrounded by a webbing of
protein fibers.
It has a thickness;
so unlike normal cell culture
where we grow them flat on a
plastic dish,
these cells are suspended
within a three-dimensional gel.
Now there's something else
in this gel here,
and that's shown here,
these are particles,
particles made of the material
alginate.
In section a few weeks ago you
all made particles like this.
We made them with food coloring
in them, but you learned the
process, it's quite
straightforward.
Imagine that instead of putting
food coloring in it like we did,
you put in a protein.
You selected that protein to be
one that encourages blood
vessels to form.
It's a protein that your body
naturally uses to cause blood
vessels to form more readily.
That protein is called vascular
endothelial growth factor,
or VEGF.
It's not important the details
but it's a signal that the body
uses to form new blood vessels.
We've isolated it,
purified it,
and encapsulated it in these
tiny particles,
which are then suspended with
the cells in the gel.
What you have here is
something that you might call a
neo-tissue, what we would like
to become a tissue when we
implant it back in the animal.
It's not a tissue yet,
it's a collection of cells and
extracellular matrix,
and signaling molecules that
are arranged in a
three-dimensional structure.
The hope is that if you put
these back into a patient or put
them back into an animal,
like the mouse shown here,
that you would grow new blood
vessels.
That's the hope.
How does this work?
This is some early work
that was done by Jordan Pober
here in the School of Medicine,
and there's a lot of pictures
here.
This is from a paper that I
could give you if you're
interested in reading in more
detail, but I want you to focus
on this one here.
What they did was they--instead
of taking this gel and putting
it right into the animal,
they maintained it in culture
for a while.
The idea was that in culture
you can control the conditions
that the neo-tissue develops
within.
Maybe you can control them in
such a way that the tissue gets
a start toward being what you
would like it to be.
In this green picture here,
I don't know if you can see it.
It's posted online and you
could blow it up and take a look
at it.
What you see is that these
cells have organized into
tube-like structures.
You'll see tubes clearly here
in this gel where you don't see
them so clearly in the other
green images here.
These are the cells I
talked about before,
the ones that are genetically
modified with the survival
protein, so that they survive in
culture.
It turns out this survival
protein also encourages their
formation into tube-like
structures that are starting to
look like blood vessels.
If you wait the proper period
of time and then implant these
gels into a mouse,
so here they just made a small
incision in the skin and slipped
the gel underneath the skin and
left it there,
then these tubes developed into
blood vessels.
Now that would be cool enough
on its own, but it does
something more,
in that this gel that's now
filled with blood vessels does
two things.
One is that the vessels start
to differentiate,
some become like capillaries,
some become like veins,
some become like arteries,
and they start to connect to
the vascular system of the
mouse.
If you wait long enough and
you look by electron microscopy
inside these gels,
you will find many,
many blood vessels that look
like this.
This is a cross-section in this
Panel B below.
You can see the endothelial
cells have formed into a
capillary, it's a tube.
Not only is it a tube but
here's a mouse blood cell inside
of it.
It's a tube that's now carrying
mouse blood through it.
You've created new pathways for
blood to flow.
Now that's a neat trick and you
could imagine using that to
treat disease.
One way you might use it to
treat disease is to implant
these things into areas of the
body that--where there aren't
enough blood vessels.
For example,
many adults get vascular
deficiencies in their legs.
These could result from trauma,
some from just the natural
process of aging,
some from diseases like
Diabetes and the blood vessels
in your legs don't work anymore.
If you're not delivering enough
blood to your leg the tissues
become ischemic or deprived of
oxygen.
What if you put one of these
patches into that area where you
weren't getting enough blood
flow and you could create new
blood flow.
That's what this experiment
shows here, treating an ischemic
limb with one of these patches.
What you see particularly in
high magnification is that lots
and lots of new blood vessels
form and they connect back to
the major vessels that are
already in the legs.
You've created new blood flow
pathways.
One could imagine using
this in the heart,
for example,
as well.
When you have tissue that's
deprived of oxygen because of a
heart attack,
for example,
or loss of flow,
that's one idea;
another idea is that you could
use these to create sort of
miniature organs.
What if instead of just putting
endothelial cells in there we
put other cells in there as
well.
What if you put liver cells in
together with the endothelial
cells and the signaling
molecules?
What if you put cells from the
pancreas in there?
Then maybe this gel would
develop not only into a
vascularized tissue,
but into a vascularized tissue
that contained liver cells or
cells from the pancreas,
or cells from the kidney.
Maybe those cells would start
to function like a little
tissue.
Maybe you could make a system
that supports the liver,
in the case the natural liver
is developing.
This is one of the central
ideas of tissue engineering.
One of the other--that I
think illustrates one of the
reasons why tissue engineering
has become a viable alternative
at this point in the scientific
culture because we know how to
culture cells,
we know how to genetically
manipulate cells,
and we know how to put them in
these kinds of
micro-environments like I've
shown.
The other thing that we've
learned how to do is--and I
mentioned this last time,
is to make synthetic materials
that could serve as artificial
extracellular matrices.
This slide shows a number of
materials that were made in
laboratories here at Yale.
One of them is a network of
fibers;
now this should look
reminiscent to the collagen
picture I showed you a few
slides ago.
It looks like a network of
fibers that are all wound
together.
Now the fibers here are much
bigger then collagen fibers.
In fact, a cell here would look
very tiny on this scanning
electron micrograph,
where it filled up the whole
thing before,
so we're thinking about fibers
at a different scale.
These are large fibers.
In fact, these are the same
kinds of fibers that are used,
same size and in some cases,
the same actual fibers that are
used to make the materials in
your clothing.
Clothing is made of fibers that
are woven together.
This is a non-woven mesh,
so the fibers are randomly
arranged, but they're fibers not
unlike the kinds of fibers you
would find in cloth material
that we make into clothing.
At high magnification these
are cylindrical fibers,
there's lots of space in
between them,
and so you could fill these
fibers up with cells and cells
would cling to the fibers and
potentially grow within this
scaffold.
This is a different kind of
architecture of a scaffold but
made of the same sort of
material, synthetic polymers.
Here instead of making fibers,
a porous structure was made
that looks like a sponge.
There are the walls of the
material that give it substance,
and there are lots of spaces in
between much larger then cells
that you could fill up with
cells.
Why use synthetic materials
when I already showed you an
example of how you could use a
natural material?
Well there's a couple of
advantages.
One is that we know a lot about
how to process synthetic
materials now.
We can make them into almost
anything that you want.
You can control their structure
on the microscopic scale,
as I've shown here.
You can control their structure
on the larger scale as well,
which I'll show you in a few
minutes.
The other advantage is that
these particular--these are
different than the kinds of
fibers that are woven into
clothing because these
intentionally degrade over time.
These are synthetic
polymers that will slowly
dissolve over a period of
months.
One could make a scaffold,
build a tissue around it,
implant it in the body,
and then this scaffolding would
slowly disappear.
What you hope is that as
the--during the time period when
this scaffolding is disappearing
genuine tissue is being formed
in its place.
That's an advantage of these
materials as well,
that because they're polymers
we can control,
to a fairly high degree,
how fast they degrade and what
products they degrade into.
This shows you an example
of tissue engineering where
these kinds of materials,
I showed you on the last slide,
so microscopically they'd look
like this up on the top panel
here.
Macroscopically,
or with your eye,
this is just a photograph from
a camera.
Y ou could make these thick
materials, full of all this
webbing of fibers,
and you could form them into
different shapes,
a triangle, a square,
or a cross in this shape here.
Now because this is a synthetic
solid material,
it maintains its shape even if
you put it into water.
Because it's a porous
material, as I showed you
before, you could fill this up
with cells.
The experiment that was done
here is that these materials,
these porous materials were
seeded with cells from
cartilage,
and the cells that make up
cartilage are called
chondrocytes.
Samples of cartilage were
obtained, digested down to
individual cells,
those cells were grown and
cultured until you had a lot of
them,
and then cells were put here,
put here, put here,
and then they were implanted
back into animals.
Here's what comes out of the
animal several months later,
and what you see is material
that looks very much like
cartilage.
A couple of things are
interesting;
one is that these things have
maintained their shapes even
though they weren't implanted
into animals for many months.
The shape that you make the
original material in leads to a
tissue that's that same shape.
If you look microscopically
inside these tissues,
you'd find that they look like
cartilage in many respects,
they look like natural
cartilage.
That is the chondrocytes,
or the individual cells that we
put on here, multiplied inside
the body,
inside the scaffold,
and they filled it up,
they filled up the space.
The tissue that you get looks
like the scaffold that you use.
This is a microscopic image
of some of those,
so imagine you cut this one
down the middle and then you
looked under a microscope.
This is what normal cartilage
looks like.
You can see the chondrocytes
here, the white regions,
and the chondrocytes excrete
and extra cellular matrix which
is stained red in this
particular preparation.
If you look at this cartilage
that was formed by tissue
engineering, you'll see some
structures here.
Some long structures,
these are residual fibers.
The polymer fibers haven't
completely degraded at this
point, but you see a lot of
cells, a lot of healthy cells.
You see they're almost at the
same density that they are in
the natural cartilage,
so the cells have multiplied to
reach sort of a natural state.
They're secreting an
extracellular matrix,
they're making their own micro
environment by secreting
molecules and so they also stain
red.
Now it's not as deep a red as
here, they're not making as much
as natural cartilage,
but they're on their way.
Here's an example of taking a
material, being able to fashion
it into a particular shape that
you want,
being able to control the
microstructure so that you can
put cells in it in such a way
that cells develop into
something that's starting to
look very much like tissue.
Now this was done in the
late 1980s I believe.
At this time,
the scientists that were doing
it were trying to make the point
that there was a lot of
potential for this kind of
strategy.
One place where you might want
to make new cartilage is in
plastic surgery.
People that have lost tissue
due to cancer or to a birth
defect, maybe they're missing
some cartilage in their nose.
There are diseases where
children are born without
functional cartilage in their
ribcage.
There are even some traumas
where people might lose an ear,
and your ear is basically skin
covered with cartilage.
They did this experiment mainly
to make a point and so I'll show
it to you.
Instead of making a
triangle or a square,
or a cross, they made a polymer
scaffold that looks a little bit
like a human ear and they filled
this scaffold--this is 100%
polymer now,
there's no tissue in here,
but then they added cartilage
cells.
They added chondrocytes and
they implanted it back into an
animal at a site where they
could easily see it.
They implanted it into the ear
of a rabbit.
Over time, what happened was
the cartilage cells that were in
this scaffold grew into
cartilage in the same shape as
the scaffold that they used.
Here's what looks like a human
ear growing on the ear of a
rabbit.
A dramatic demonstration,
and when they took this ear out
of the rabbit,
obviously it's not a real ear,
it doesn't hear,
but it has--it's all the
cartilage that forms the outer
part of your ear.
If you took a section of this
later and looked inside,
it would look just like the
cartilage that's inside your
ear.
You could use this same
strategy to make other kinds of
tissues as well.
I'm going to return to the
example of coronary arteries
because that's such a big
medical problem around the
world;
coronary heart disease.
Heart disease is either the
number one or number two killer
around the world.
Certainly in countries that are
developed like the U.S.,
heart disease and cancer are
the leading causes of death.
A lot of the death from heart
disease comes from failure of
your coronary arteries.
One of the most performed
surgical operations in the
United States is coronary artery
bypass surgery.
You probably all know somebody
who has got it,
maybe a grandparent or a family
friend.
It's not an uncommon surgery
and it's not perfect yet,
and we talked about the ways
that it's not perfect last time.
What if you could grow,
outside of the body,
blood vessels that you could
use to replace the vessels
inside of a patient?
People have been working on
this for a long time.
Here's an initial attempt.
This is a tube that was made of
a polymer, and in this case it
was a polymer.
It was a natural polymer
collagen, so sort of like that
collagen gel that I talked about
several slides ago that we
suspended the endothelial cells
in,
only this time it's made into
the form of a tube.
The idea was to take those
endothelial cells and coat the
inside of this tube with
endothelial cells.
Make a tube that's mechanically
strong that will stay like a
tube, but coat it with the
natural cells that form the
lining inside your blood
vessels.
Allow it to develop and
culture, to the point where you
have a natural endothelial cell
lining,
and then implant this back into
an animal in place of its own
artery.
What you hope is that blood
will flow through here,
and it should flow because
there's an opening,
and that the blood won't clot,
because now instead of an
artificial material you have a
lining of blood vessel cells on
the inside.
This is a picture from
studies that were done in the
early 1980s on this approach and
there was some success.
You could make them work for
some period of time,
but they always eventually
failed,
and I won't go through the
whole history of this but
there's a long history of people
trying different materials,
different ways of putting cells
on different sources of cells.
All the things that you could
imagine changing,
and all of them working for a
little while and then failing.
You can imagine it's a hard
engineering problem,
a difficult engineering
problem,
because you need to make this
material strong enough that it
serves as a vessel.
It's got to withstand blood
pressure, not burst.
It's got to be strong enough to
put a stitch into because you've
got to sew this into the natural
artery.
It's got to have good
mechanical properties on its own
but still allow the formation of
a natural tissue around it.
All those criteria turn out to
be difficult to meet.
I want to talk in detail
about an advance that was made
by someone who's now here at
Yale, a woman named Lauren
Niklason.
She's in our department of
Biomedical Engineering and
Anesthesiology.
When she started looking at
this problem,
she thought,
'Well, everything that's done
is working kind of but it's not
quite working well enough.'
The vessels when you put them
in the body they don't develop
the way that normal vessels do,
they don't develop a normal
structure.
She thought maybe that's
because we're not exposing them
to the kinds of environments
that arteries normally develop
under.
When our arteries developed
during embryonic development
they developed as the heart
developed.
While they were developing and
turning from just collections of
cells into arterial tissue,
they were exposed to flowing
blood because the embryonic
heart was already beating,
there's already an immature
circulatory system.
These arteries developed in the
presence of a beating heart.
What if you simulated that
in cell culture and took these
tissue engineered structures
that are polymer scaffolds
filled with the right kinds of
cells.
You hook them up to--on both
ends to a tube where you can
expose them to blood flow and
blood pressure and build a
reactor around these blood
vessels,
so that as they're developing
outside the body.
You can control the conditions
that they're grown under so that
it's close to the conditions
that a natural artery would
experience when it's developing
inside an embryo.
This shows some of the things
that she did in order to create
this environment.
Here's a picture of a
bioreactor, here is an
artificial blood vessel that she
made in the laboratory.
Again, this is a polymer
scaffold, the same kind of
scaffold I showed you several
slides ago of a material,
a network, an unwoven fiber
mesh, and formed into a tube.
Smooth muscle cells or the
internal cells of the artery are
cultured inside,
and then it's placed in this
reactor.
You can see it's hooked up to
two tubes here,
so blood is constantly flowing
through the inside.
It's flowing in a pulsatile
manner just like our blood is
flowing through our coronary
arteries or our artery.
She found that if she did
this they developed into tissues
that looked much,
much more like real arteries
and that you could take these
and implant them into animals.
One is shown here,
in the carotid,
this is in the neck of a large
animal, I think either a sheep
or a pig I'm not sure which one.
It's stitched into place,
the animal then leaves the
operating room with a new blood
vessel which you can study by
using imaging techniques.
You can follow this blood
vessel.
They've done this for many,
many months now,
even years in some cases.
You can form vessels that are
smaller than any that have been
transplanted in this way and
they maintain their function in
culture.
I show this because it's an
exciting example of tissue
engineering.
It's also, I think,
a good illustration of one of
the advantages of tissue
engineering,
in that you can create a tissue
outside by arranging things
together.
You can maintain it under
controlled conditions in the
laboratory until its ready to be
transplanted.
Then, you can transplant it at
the right time.
All of these things are under
control so it could be optimized
to produce the best quality
tissue.
In this case,
they've cultured the vessels
for eight weeks in order to get
the kind of function that they
want.
I think you can imagine from
these examples I've shown you,
lots of different ways that you
could build outside the body
neo-tissues or structures that
will develop into,
hopefully, real tissues.
This illustration is just
to sort of show you all of the
kinds of tissues that,
at this point in time,
people have tried to make using
tissue engineering approaches.
Many of you might know Erin
Lavik in our Biomedical
Engineering Department,
who's been working and has some
fabulous results on tissue
engineering to create spinal
cords,
to treat injured spinal cords.
There's many examples like this.
There's already tissue
engineered skin that's available
for physicians to use.
The other thing I tried to show
you with this diagram is that
what you're trying to achieve
while you might be using the
same approaches that I've shown
here,
you're trying to achieve
different things in different
tissues.
Some things you're trying
to replace structure,
mainly.
If I'm trying to use this
approach to make new bone I'm
trying to make new structural
material.
What I care about is the
mechanical properties of the
tissue that I create;
at least I care about that a
lot.
A bone that cannot
form--perform the mechanical
functions of bone is not a very
good bone.
It has to have the right
elastic modulus,
which we talked about earlier.
In other tissues you're trying
to replace metabolism or the
cellular biochemistry that goes
on inside the cells.
In the liver,
you don't care so much about
the mechanical properties of the
liver,
you care that all the cells are
performing all the metabolic
properties that a liver
ordinarily performs;
that table of things I showed
you last time.
In the pancreas,
in the same way,
you're trying to create a
tissue that forms a metabolic
function.
In the pancreas,
one of the most important
metabolic functions is that it
senses glucose and secretes
insulin in response to glucose.
You don't care about the
structure you care about the
metabolism.
There are some things like
blood vessels where you're in
between.
A blood vessel needs to perform
the mechanical function,
needs to serve as a physical
plumbing to carry blood from one
place to another.
It also performs a biological
function, it carries the blood
and it anti-coagulates at the
same time, it stops coagulation.
There are many other
biochemical functions that blood
vessels perform.
The next aspect of tissue
engineering I want to focus on
is that tissue engineering often
uses cellular processes to
control drug delivery.
This provides a new way to do
drug delivery to supplement the
kinds of engineering approaches
we talked about a few weeks ago.
Now how might you do that?
Well, let's imagine,
just look on this side of the
slide here, and imagine you have
a hollow fiber.
A hollow fiber is a fiber that
has an outside diameter,
and then it's hollow on the
inside, made of some kind of
synthetic material.
It might look like a straw,
like a straw that you drink
through, only the straw has
special properties.
In general it's much,
much thinner than a drinking
straw would be.
This might be a millimeter
across instead of several
millimeters like a drinking
straw would be.
You fill this up with
cells, you fill up the hollow
fiber with cells.
The fiber is a special material
in that: 1) it's biocompatible
so you can implant it in the
body and the body doesn't
respond adversely to it,
and 2) it has a controlled
porosity so that molecules can
pass in and out.
It's porous,
it allows molecules to pass in
and out but it doesn't allow
cells to pass in and out.
It's a filter,
it's a porous filter that
allows small molecules to go in
and out, but doesn't allow large
molecules to go in and out.
Now, if this is filled up
with cells.
I show this cut away so that
you can see inside.
Here's little clusters of cells
growing inside,
but it's a full cylinder in
reality.
The ends are sealed and I
implant this into the body.
Let's say I put it into the
abdominal cavity or I put it
under the skin.
What you would like,
then, is for these cells to be
able to communicate with the
body through molecules but not
directly.
They're isolated from the body
because this hollow fiber is
surrounding them everywhere.
What if these were cells from
the pancreas?
Then, maybe glucose,
blood sugar,
could diffuse or move through
the wall of this hollow fiber,
exposing these cells to
glucose.
The cells would sense the
glucose is there because they're
cells from the pancreas and
they're functioning normally.
They would secrete insulin in
response to glucose.
The insulin would flow out,
and then into blood vessels
outside here.
Now why go to all this
trouble?
Why not just inject these cells
right into the body?
Why surround them by this
hollow fiber?
What do you think would happen
if you just injected them under
the skin or you injected them
into the abdominal cavity?
Caitlin?Student:
There would be an
infection.Professor Mark
Saltzman: They would be
recognized as foreign by the
immune system,
unless they were your cells.
You need this treatment because
your cells aren't working
properly so you don't have any
pancreas cells to contribute.
The cells either have to come
from somebody else,
an allograph,
foreign to you.
It could even be a zenograph;
it might be cells from another
species.
They might be cells from a pig,
for example.
It turns out that the insulin
that pigs make is very similar
to human insulin.
Not exactly the same but very
similar.
So, for decades and decades,
until we discovered ways to
make recombinant human insulin
in the 1980s,
pig insulin was the primary
source of insulin to treat
diabetics.
Why not use cells from a
species where cells are readily
available and put them inside of
a capsule like this so that
they're separated from your
immune system but still able to
function as a pancreas?
In a sense, it's functioning as
a drug delivery system.
The drug here is insulin.
It's a smart drug delivery
system, and it has the
intelligence of the cells that
are encapsulated inside.
It's smart in what way?
It's smart in effect that it
can detect the presence of
glucose and secrete insulin only
when glucose is present and
insulin is needed.
If this was used to treat
Diabetes, if you were a diabetic
you wouldn't have to be checking
your glucose levels and
adjusting how much you inject
because you'd have a system
inside your body that's doing it
automatically in the way,
hopefully, that a normal
pancreas is.
What I show on the left
hand side of the graph here is
some different configurations
that people have now made using
this same concept.
It doesn't have to be a hollow
fiber, but you can make a
micro-capsule like this.
Remember when you made the
alginate particles in the
section meeting?
We mentioned that not only
could you put food coloring
inside these particles but maybe
you could put cells inside
these--and you can.
You can put cells inside these
particles and make little
capsules that have cells on the
inside but are surrounded by a
barrier that keeps them away
from the immune system.
There are a variety of other
ways of doing this as well.
This next slide,
just shows you the advantage of
this strategy,
here the dashed line is the
membrane whether it's formed by
a hollow fiber or an
alginate--or a hydrogel seal,
engineered cells are on the
inside.
Now, I talked about putting
cells from an animal inside but
maybe you could genetically
engineer beta-cells so that they
function for a long time.
Maybe you could take a
patient's own diseased cells and
genetically engineer them so
they work properly and then give
them back.
Maybe you could take cells from
the pancreas of an individual
donor, genetically engineer them
so that they grow in culture,
and then they'd be available to
treat lots of patients.
The idea is that nutrients,
oxygen, glucose can come
inside, insulin can come back
out, but that the immune system
won't recognize it as foreign.
Now, this is an idea that's
also been around for a long
time.
There's been a lot of people
that have worked on it,
great progress has been made.
It turns out to be a
tremendously challenging
engineering problem because you
need to engineer a material
that's compatible with the body
that doesn't--that allows only
the passage of certain molecules
and not other molecules.
It has to allow insulin to pass
but not antibodies.
It has to do that very reliably
without allowing any immune
system components to come
inside, and it has to do it at a
high enough rate.
You have to not only allow
insulin to go through;
you have to allow it to go
through in large quantities so
that you can provide enough
insulin in order to treat
Diabetes without having a huge
device.
It needs to be small and
produce a lot of insulin.
These turn out to be challenges
that we haven't quite achieved
yet.
Let me just summarize what
we've talked about.
In the field of tissue
engineering, which I think
you're going to see make a lot
of progress during your
lifetime.
A logical extension of
conventional medical and
surgical practices,
it involves the control or
regulation of normal healing.
We talked about tissue
engineering approaches that use
cells and tissue engineering
approaches that don't use cells,
where the material or some
other aspect of what you're
using controls the healing
process.
We talked about tissue
engineering to supplement the
cellular component,
and even to guide the ways that
cells form into new tissues to
control drug delivery.
This last aspect,
which I think you can probably
see more clearly now then when I
mentioned it last time,
is that now you could use these
new tissues that are created in
the laboratory to understand
physiology better.
You could take Dr.
Niklason's tissue engineered
blood vessels and use them to
understand more about how blood
vessels develop during embryonic
development,
because she's created a system
where she can control many of
the key variable.
You could add cells at
different time and see how this
developing tissue responds to
that.
You could add signaling
molecules at different times and
see how this developing tissue
remodels or responds to these
signals that you added.
These turn out to get very
powerful tools,
not only for creating new
therapies but for understanding
human physiology.
I'm going to stop there but
there's some time for questions.
It could be questions about
this or last minute questions
about your papers that are due
tomorrow.
Any questions about that?
I know I've answered quite a
few by email,
it seemed like everybody was on
the right track.
No, everybody's good?
Good, so I'll see you in
section this afternoon.